this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everybody uh to the fall seminar
series for
um small crop sciences um we have a
strong lineup of
presentations including some panels
later on and we have a lot of student
presenters for the semester
so we're delighted to begin today with
linka who's in elena's lab
uh who will be uh well i think i'll let
you
explain the title of your talk and give
the title of your talk
um a couple rules on the road for the
day
um if you have a question while linka is
speaking
please type it into the chat and i or
lenka will
read it and answer it at the end of the
session
uh and then time committing will also
open the florida questions
at that point so without any further ado
welcome thank you a lot for
attending and elena over to you to
introduce olenka
thank you andy so well hello everyone
it's unusual seminar series unusual of
the unusual
semester um well first of all i would
like to take this opportunity to
introduce our new
phd students um unfortunately two can
be here virtually
um and it's clear crowley maybe hear a
wave or say hi so that
a lot of people here oh some people here
know me already but
i'm sure there's some people i don't
know too but i'm a new phd student with
andy mcdonald's
right and kiera was an ms student
with ryan was not ryan that's right
yeah so i came back
and uh sophie westbrook
sophie good to meet you all i'm a new ms
phd student with pony d tommaso
unfortunately two pg students uh jaming
lai
and then chilo they cannot be with us
because it's actually midnight
past midnight in china so chen shi and
uh jeremiah they are students with
yin-san
and jia mang she is she's actually
enrolled in taking classes uh she'll
join us
probably at the end of the semester and
a chance you will join us hopefully
in the spring and so
yeah so welcome welcome to the family
um and now i would like to introduce
solenka although i think for many of
our pg students doesn't need a lot of
introduction because she's very active
in our graduate student association so
she served as a vice
president and last year was a president
and i think
uh now she's ready to pass the torch
to a new generation so i'm encouraging
all the students to be very active
you say you know would you say so olenka
originally is from ukraine uh from the
same city that i am
from review which is you know in a
western border
with poland and that's where she was uh
you know born uh raised and that's where
she obtained her bachelor degree
she graduated from the uh
national it's it's before it was leave
national university now is
national university of relief there is
changes i actually graduated from the
same university too
so uh so it's a pleasure for me to host
alanka solanka came
to us in 2015 and she initially joined
my lab
as a technical assistant
and then she decided she want to
continue she actually switched because
she did
her bachelor's are in genetics and
biotechnology
and uh back in ukraine she was working
with microorganisms and trying to
engineer microbes that can serve as
factories for
antibiotics and so she switched to plans
and she found that she has to be very
patient with plans because it's not 12
hours of
you know she cannot get results in in
overnight so she has to wait and wait
and wait and then wait some more and so
so um and i think in 2017 olanka
uh started her phd msphd and now she is
post her exam actually today is her
pre-a
post a seminar she successfully passed
her
a exam in june and
she is already co-authored on two
publications and
is studying her research project
that will lead to her first author
publication hopefully
within the next several years and
olanka's seminar title
is quite long but briefly what she's
going to talk today about is
about the transcription regulators
which are involved in the regulation of
copper and iron homeostasis
in the global crop wheat and prohibition
and i think with this i'll pass it to
lenka
thank you um hi everyone
uh welcome to the seminar series um
it's quite unusual to not be speaking to
a room full of people
so i'm just speaking to many rooms with
each person in them so
i'm going to start with explaining what
my talk's about
and if you have any questions feel free
to ask them
so uh the topic of my presentation is
establishing the role
of cyclone-like genes in the regulation
of copper and iron homeostasis
and reproduction in wheat and its model
brush podium
so here's sorry
i need to switch it here's a short
outline of
what i will be talking about so uh i
will be talking about
a bit uh micronutrient deficiencies and
how they're connected to food security
but pros of iron and copper about the
bhlh family of transcription factors
that are involved
in plant mineral homeostasis and how
they're connected to crops
and obviously i will give you some idea
of what work i'm currently doing
in the lab so why do we need to be
interested in micronutrients such as
copper and iron and what is their role
in food security
uh to answer this question let's figure
out what
actually is food security or or
basically
one of the problems is food insecurity
so food insecurity is defined as the
situation where people lack
secure access to sufficient amounts of
safe and nutritious food for normal
growth and development
and an active healthy life and about
800 million individuals across the world
are considered
undernourished and even though yuan had
set
this global goal to end hunger by 2030
we're
currently pretty far from reaching that
target
as some of the countries currently have
food deficit
that are below 200 kilocalories per
person per day
however we have to realize that calorie
deficit is not the only
indicator of undernourishment and
this leads me to talking about
micronutrient deficiencies
in humans since a term
called hidden hunger is actually a form
of
under nutrition that occurs when intake
and absorption of vitamins and minerals
are too
low to sustain good health and
development
so
uh obviously uh deficiencies of
micronutrients
uh will show some symptoms in people and
iron deficiency is uh most
well-known i suppose
as anemia so symptoms of anemia
here you can see on the map are usually
among
preschool aged children you can
see it right away and the symptoms are
usually
extreme fatigue weakness called hands
and feet
and pale skin however if you look at
copper deficiency symptoms they're
pretty similar
uh the reason for that is actually
copper is pretty important for iron
absorption
so it's really connected together in uh
humans for them to be more healthy they
really do need these micronutrients
and um as you can see from this map
particularly acute cases of anemia
are uh in the countries where people are
uh less fortunate with resources and
have to rely on plant by based
diet only so
one of the ways to resolve this
issue is uh biofortification
uh biofertification is a process that
increases
bioavailability of uh and the
concentration of nutrients in crops both
convention by conventional plant
breeding efforts
and through biotechnology
since a fortification of foods can be
performed in some countries where
it can be added globally for example
we add iodine to salt however
biofortification will probably benefit
more
places that are more uh rural and
uh that way you already will have the
plant that
is able to uh get all of its nutrients
and increase the amount of
nutritional value
right away so
since plants take their nutrients from
the soil
if they actually lack some of them you
would be able to see it
uh on the plant right away uh
so symptoms of
some of them are uh pretty cute for
example
for the symptom of iron deficiency you
can see that plants
uh have this interventional proclorosis
of young leaves which is like
a huge yellow flag i would say
not the red flag uh to to show that
something's wrong with your plant
uh among other symptoms are obviously
swelling of root tips
uh and in acute cases even a
full crop failure uh symptoms of copper
deficiency however
can be a verb a bit more subtle uh
it's uh again decreased growth
rate and uh chlorosis uh however uh
another thing that you can see is um
impaired magnification of cell walls
which results in
curling of the leaves and weaker stems
and
lodging another thing is
flower abortion and as a result a lower
seed and grain fat
so uh why the nutrient deficiencies
occur
well one of the reasons would be that um
micronutrient availability really
fluctuates depending
uh on the soils they're in and um more
than 30 percent
of world's arable land are considered to
be iron and copper deficient
since their ph are alkaline and neutral
which makes uh these uh
micronutrients unavailable
even though micronutrients is important
for our health
we have to remember that in high amounts
they can be toxic
and therefore plants need to know how to
regulate their
uptake and transport uh using proteins
called transcription factors or tfs as
i will be referring to them later
so um as i was mentioning
iron causes such an uh issue as
anemia so it has been studied more
extensively
one of the most important
transporters that help uptake iron in
the plants is called irt1 so
i just want you to remember this name
and
the processes of iron uptake really vary
in different plants at first
they were really strictly divided to two
strategies such as reduction strategy
and collation strategy
and reduction strategy was considered to
only be
uh used by dicots and non-grass monocots
so they would reduce iron iii to iron
two to
take it up and a chelation strategy was
more uh preferable for grasses where
they
extrude chelate such as phytocederoforce
and then
iron iii gets chelated and taken up
however the more iron was studies
the the more we knew about it
and actually this division came
uh to be shortened
and you could see that actually uh
the uptake of iron two by iot one can
happen in uh plants from both strategies
all of these processes however are
controlled by
the transcription factors and
specifically by the bhlh family of
transcription factors
so from here i want you to remember bhla
family of transcription factors and
the iot one
so moving on we will talk about
that copper unlike iron hasn't been
studied
that much
so for a long time the only
transcription factor that
regulated uh copper deficiency symptoms
that has been known uh for
to everyone uh was actually spl seven
and uh until recently
uh that was the only real
uh a big
way to know of regulation of copper
homeostasis
is to look at sp07 however
[Music]
a student in a lab japan you probably
remember her
actually discovered that there is
another transcription factor that
regulates
copper homeostasis and it's called catf1
so um here you can see uh
that she worked on um arabidopsis plants
which is
a model for dicot plants
and uh what i want you to pay attention
to here is
uh here you can see the sleeks that have
grains inside of them so here you can
see the wild type
of sleeks that is filled with grains
and you could look at catf1
and sp07 mutant that generally still
have
grains however if you look at the double
mutant of capf 1 and sp07
the plant that lacks both of these
transcription factors
you can see that there are no grains
inside because it's
turned out to be 90 infertile
and that is something that was really
interesting
to us and we decided to see well
how do we know that it's actually copper
that we have to look at for this we
employed
this method that's called synchrodrone
x-ray fluorescent microscopy and
uh my lab mage rujan was working
at synchrotron uh source here at cornell
which is actually across the field from
bradfield
and what was found
is you can actually visualize
all the minerals you need
in the tissues of plants using uh
this technique and here you can see the
density of copper in the flowers
of arabidopsis so here you can see
wild-type plants that actually have
plenty of copper in their flowers and
specifically in the anthers
those um warmer colors
show a higher uh density uh
later you look when we look at uh
different mutants you can see that
copper density actually goes down
uh it's lower in catf1 mutant it's even
lower in
sp07 mutant and it's basically not there
in
the doubling extent so um
it's very interesting
so since citf1
seems to play an important role we
decided
to look at its place among other bhlh
transcription factors
and um did a phylogenetic tree of
more than 160 bhlh genes and
this is the close-up of of that uh big
tree
and what i want you to see is here is
catf1 and it's um
controlling copper homeostasis however
it is
in the same clade as some of the
transcription factors that are
involved in iron homeostasis so that so
again
copper and iron uh come together
um
so all of that was actually studied in
arabidopsis and dicots however
how are copper transport processes
regulated in grasses
that include global crops such as wheat
rice and corn is not well studied
that's why it's of interest to me
so for these studies we've chosen to
concentrate on wheat as one of the most
important crops
and its model pressure podium the reason
i use brachiopodium as a model for weed
is
because its genome is less complex
it's smaller it's fully sequenced it has
the plant has shorter life cycle smaller
stature
and it's more aminable to genetic
transformation
um so it's really cool it's
considered to be a model but we decided
to make sure that uh
our results are reproducible so uh we
decided to compare the response
uh to copper of uh
fresh podium compared to wheat and see
if
these results are actually reproducible
uh so here you can see that
we've grown uh both wheat and
prohibition
uh on different concentrations of copper
from zero to 500 nanomolar
and what we did we evaluated
the amount of flowers that are being
produced
and amount of grains that are being
produced
depending on uh concentration of copper
the plants were grown
in and something i want you to pay
attention to
is that for example if you look at
uh plants grown at 15 nanomolar copper
uh you can if you look at the number of
flowers yeah they're
bigger than uh with like zero copper for
example there there's a larger amount of
flowers over here
uh or over here so here you can see
wheat flowers and broccodium flowers
however
if you want to look at the grains the
number of grains goes down
which indicates that copper is pretty
important for
uh grain yield in both in wheat and
pressure podium
since like you would be going down the
field for example
and you see beautiful flowers and there
are a lot of flowers
in the field and you're like it seems
i'll get a nice yield this year however
as you can see um the amount of flowers
doesn't necessarily mean that he'll get
brain yield
and so this little test showed us
that indeed brachiopodium uh
shows results uh that are comparable to
results in
wheat so obviously i can use it as a
model
for wheat studies in my later studies
so what i did next is i decided to look
if there are any scetf1 like genes
in a wheat and pressure podium and found
that indeed
catf1 does have
several homologues both in wheat and
richarlium
and i designated one them c a t f
l from sixth one like uh one two
and three for wheat and c a t f l one
two and three in brexit podium
so uh this leads me to my specific
objectives for my phd studies
which are established the role of catfl
in copper and iron homeostasis and
reproduction in prehispodium
as well as in wheat identified genes
regulated by catfish
and wheat and brychipodium established
the relationship
of catfl to the sp07 pathway
in regards to copper transport processes
and reproduction
and analyze protein protein interaction
of catfl transcription factors
so um i started with
looking at the expression levels of
my genes in different tissues of
brushy podium and saw that they're
highly expressed
in stems flag leaves
for catfish one and two and in roots for
c8fl3 so
basically those are the tissues you
would use
i would use for later
expression studies which i did
and uh if you look here i
uh looked at the expression of catfl
one two and three uh under copper and
iron deficiency
and as you can see uh here
is a full difference of ratio uh
so ratio between um
the copper or iron deficiency and
control conditions and you can see
that all three of them are actually
upregulated under deficiency conditions
uh which is pretty cool it's something
that
i wanted to see and uh to test the
biological
relevance of this increasing expression
um and uh to see
if is it is it important enough or not
um i need to make mutants of these genes
so um i decided to use the crispr cas9
genome editing
system and uh just to remind you how it
works so
uh the components of this editing system
are genomic dna that
you're going to be editing a guide rna
that
you actually design uh to
lead the system uh to add it in specific
place you want to add it and
a nuclease cas9 which actually does the
cutting
so the cas9 forms the complex with guide
rnas and the guide rna
finds and attaches to the sequence and
genomic dna the one
that you plan for it after which the
complex cuts the sequence
and um after that the genomic dna is
being repaired
and the mutations are introduced in the
process
of preparation uh so i will show you
um on an example
of how i made my mutant from catfl1
so here you can see a genomic dna
sequence of catfl1 and i generated
guide rnase the reason
i generated more than one guide rna is
because i wanted to make a deletion
uh out of this gene so if you make two
guide rnas you
uh and you can
have um this chunk of around 500 base
pairs
to be cut out of your gene
uh so the reason we have several
uh guide rnas is because we're trying
different combinations to see
which one of them works out so uh
for example for me uh the one that
worked out
was combination one plus three and
uh my expected uh edited
size would be around a thousand base
pairs
so that's what happened the nucleases
cut in the process and this whole chunk
of dna was cut out after which it was
repaired
and here you can see um
the end result uh however
this is just what's actually happening
during the editing
um but it takes
so much more time and effort to actually
get the mutant
since transformation of pressure podium
is a bit of a long
process so first you have to start
with uh they say extracting the embryos
of breast
podium then initiated callus and
after co-culturing uh colors with
the bacteria that has your construct you
have to select
it on appropriate antibiotics and then
regenerate it as
you can see all of this takes a lot of
time
and effort until you can finally have
your mutant plants however
the fact that you got the plants doesn't
necessarily mean that all the editing
happened
for this we have to do some checking and
uh the way we do it is each of the
plants we
regenerated we collect their tissues
extract their genomic dna
and run a pcr uh and here
uh you could see the expected results of
uh
dna electrophoresis so
if editing didn't happen uh the result
will be
similar to the wild type so it will be
around 1.5 kb
a band on the electrophoresis gel
however if your editing did happen uh
in my case it's an editing of
1 000 base pairs so uh
here on the 0.5 kb you can see a band
and that will mean you have a homozygous
mutant
however if you see both vents on the gel
that means you got a heterozygous mutant
so in order to get a homozygous mutant
you will get
you will need to get later generations
of plants
another thing to look for is whether
cas9 nucleates is still
inside the plant uh as you know it's
very useful because it does all the
editing however
uh you kind of wanted to edit and then
go away
and not to keep doing the work all the
time
since you need to know actually
what type of editing happened and you
need to know it's not happening anymore
so for that you also perform
a pcr that detects for the cas9
and mutants that still have cast 9
and have the band of approximately 0.7
kb
however both mutants that already don't
have the cas9 and the wild type
won't have any bands so here i will see
i will show you the obtain results and
as you can see i've obtained four mutant
lines
three of them are homozygous and one of
them is heterozygous however when i
looked for the cast nine
i saw that only line number one
was cast nine free and this is the one
that i'm using in my further studies
so after i found
that my mutant was obtained
i needed to sequence it to see
what deletion i got what is the size
where it is so
uh it showed me that i got a thousand
one hundred and thirteen base pairs
deletion so
approximately the size i was planning
for
and um what you do later is
you have to look if the mutant shows any
phenotype
this is what i did so um i grew it
on different media
that is control media with
all of the necessary nutrients iron
deficient media
and copper deficient media and as you
can see
uh for from my preliminary data that
even in control conditions the mutant is
has smaller stature so it already shows
some phenotype
and under deficiency conditions it seems
to have
a lower amount of leads
so this is my preliminary data i
just finally got my mutant so that's
something i will
keep analyzing in the future
another thing uh that i wanted to look
at is
uh whether catf1 is connected to spl7
in the brasses since they are connected
in
uh the dicots so um
uh my lab mate hua jin jiang for
he was working on the sp07 homolog
in brahipodium and he found that
it is required for copper uptake
delivery to flag leaves florence and
fertility
so here you can again see the results of
x-ray fluorescent microscopy studies
and these are the flowers of prehipodium
and as you can see in comparison
the mutant doesn't have a lot of copper
in the flowers
[Music]
so i decided to
use his mutant to look at
the expression of my catfl genes and
see if there's a connection so what i
expect
is if the transcription factor which is
sp07 in this case
uh if it actually
somehow regulates your chain of interest
we will see changes in the gene
expression of
mutant plants however if it doesn't uh
there will be no change in gene
expression
so that's what i did i looked at both
wild type and spss
mutant and stiff in different tissues
and um all three
catfl genes were actually
regulated by spl7 in prehypodium
however uh for example uh
catf 1 and 2 were down regulated
in roots uh and young leaves uh however
cfl 3 for example was upregulated
in the old leaves so changes in
regulation
show me that indeed there's connection
between catfl and spls7
well one of the other things i did is
i used bioinformatic approach to uh
look at other potential interactors for
my
catfil genes and i used a gene
regulatory network that
predicts uh the interactions for
my genes of interest with and i found
that
most of them are connected to iron
homeostasis so i don't want you to like
remember
all of these names there are a lot of
them and it's usually an online software
that predicts
all of it and you just pick something
that's of interest to you at the moment
so um
what i want you to pay attention is to
irt one
that actually has a connection
with a ca tfl1 and i will remind you
that
rt1 is actually an iron uptake
transporter
as i already mentioned and another thing
i wanted to remind you is that
ca tf1 in arabidopsis is
in the same clade as transcription
factors that are involved in iron
homeostasis
so uh what i decided to do is to see
whether
iot one is possibly regulated by catfl1
in brexit podium so
again the same type of
scheme you can see here if transcription
factor
regulates gene of interest i will see
changes in expression of mutant plans
if it doesn't i won't see any changes in
expression
and uh indeed i actually saw changes in
expression
for um iot one uh
in my cafl1 mutant
uh and that means that uh
possibly that cakfl1 actually
uh regulates um
iot 1 and potentially
other iron related transporters
um another thing i wanted to look at
is to see how my chfl
[Music]
transcription factors act so one of the
peculiar things
about uh the bhlh family of
transcription factors
is they uh cannot act alone they have to
be paired up
uh or dimerized to act and
the way they do it is
they have several domains on them and
part of them are responsible for
a protein protein interaction so uh
this is the part that would be
responsible for protein protein
interaction so
um one of the phlh family members
will connect their
protein-protein interaction part to
the same part in a partner that is
uh another member of the bhlh family
transcription factors and if they
connect together
as you see over here these uh
proteins are connected and then they
kind of assemble in a way that they both
can interact with dna and attach it
to it uh so
uh one of the things you could do uh
and one of the things i did is
uh look at possible interactors
among other phlh family members
and here you can see
yeast studies that were used for it
so basically i decided to see if my
prehipodium catfl
one two and three are interacting or not
so um the way you pair them up you can
pair them up
as a ctfl one with ctfl1
maybe it needs two of them to act or
see if l1 with c8fl2 so
either type of combinations
and i tried most of them however the
only
uh one that actually showed an
interaction was
ctfl1 with chfl1 so
two proteins need to interact and
uh if interaction happens over here you
will see the growth
on the selection media uh on the
quadruple dropout selection media
or on the selection media that actually
shows the blue color so the blue color
is there there is an interaction
and if it's not there is no interaction
and indeed these results show that
there is an interaction between ctfl1
and c8tfl1 uh
and that is pretty cool and
i hope to also work on uh
looking for some other bhlh members that
might interact with my catfish
so uh in conclusion i want you to
remember
several things which are cdtfl
one two and three in pressure podium are
upregulated by copper and iron
deficiency
cakfl1 mutant in brachipodium that was
generated using crispr
cas9 gene editing system shows
that uh the new the the preliminary
study showed that the mutant growth slow
grows slower and actually shows
uh sensitivity to iron copper
deficiencies
uh i also found that uh
irt-1 is down-regulated in ca tfl-1
mutant which
suggests that uh ctfl-1 transcription
factor regulates
iron uptake transporter irt-1
i also found that catfl's are regulated
by sp07 which shows insight into copper
homeostasis network
and i also found that citfl1 interacts
with itself and used to hybrid
studies so there's still some work
left to do for me
with establishing the role of catf1 and
copper and iron homeostasis and
reproduction
i plan to test the sensitivity of the
mutant to copper and iron deficiency
test the ability of it to accumulate
copper and iron in its tissues
adjust the fertility of the mutant and
compare it to the wild-type plants
i would also want to establish the
relationship between catfl1
mutants to spl cell and pathway
in relation to copper transport
processes
and for this i would like to generate a
double mutant between c8fl1
and sp07 and look at the phenotype of
this double mutant and analyze its
flower development and morphology
another thing i want to do is i identify
more genes
regulated by catfl1 and for this i will
use a deep transcriptome analysis
uh rna-seq to identify the genes that
are regulated
by ctfl one in different tissues under
uh copper and iron deficiency conditions
and i would also like to use uh east
studies to see whether cdfl1 is
binding to rt1 uh to do these studies i
actually got the schmittau novak
integrative plant science smoke grant uh
for this year uh so yeah i've got the
funding to do what i
want to do um and
um so um i would like
to show you that out of the specific
objectives of my phd work
i talked about four of them uh
however the uh establishment of the role
of ctfs
and copper homeostasis and reproduction
in wheat
is a more complicated process since
uh oh i'm not able to make a mutant on
my own we're going to collaborate with
a plant transformation facility with
matthew wilman there and
they will be taking care of our
mutants and once i get mutants from
wheat
i will repeat uh all of the work that
i've done with c8fl1 and
still plan to do with catfl 2 and 3 in
pressure podium
i will repeat the same work in wheat
once
um plant transformation facility gets me
those mutants
and with that i would like to thank all
of my
lab members thank you my
to my committee and our collaborators
and funding and with that i would be
happy to take any questions
thank you um
well done so uh questions
yeah i've you know you since i didn't
see any questions in chat so
just drink some someone raised hey yeah
uh oh hi tim sutter here
uh i have a question uh
so so the work uh that you presented of
your own
and also of your colleagues is showing
a particular importance of copper and
iron
in the reproductive organs can you
explain why
the reproductive organs have this
special need for for
copper and iron so
um as you can see for example
sorry i'll click real quick
[Music]
here um so as you can see here
uh we looked at
uh different concentrations uh of copper
and like
how uh different plants react to them
and um as we've shown in
uh uh xrf studies that
uh in mute in copper
regulation mutants uh copper is not
there and
as you might have noticed i showed the
anthers
uh and as part of the
reproductive system so one of the
interesting things is enter the histones
so apparently if you
don't have enough copper uh the hunters
won't de-hiss and pollen won't be viable
since copper takes part in a lot of
processes such as lignification which is
important for
anthra-dehiscence and is also
taking part in so many cell processes
such as electron transport processes so
basically you get the energy
um in the cell uh however
if there isn't enough copper some of
these processes are not happening so
pollen is not viable and
therefore fertility
goes down and you cannot get the yield
okay thank you johannes has
his hand up hi yeah um
thank you very much uh looks great um i
had a question to the synchrotron
studies
um and uh um
one thing that that we had always
problem with
is if if we uh compare different
measurements
um the intensity uh is very difficult
to compare are you are you putting
the same are you putting all the samples
into the same view to be able to compare
them
um or or are there some ways to
to normalize um the the intensity and
the second question was
is there a way to also say something
about the copper forms that would be
instructive for you um in addition to
the spatial
um the spatial distribution is there any
any hidden opportunity there
what would be interested to know thanks
thank you for your question so uh as for
x-ray of studies our uh the the more
professional person to ask
in our lab is rujan she is actually the
one who's using all of this
uh however i will try to answer your
question better
uh so uh yes these
concentrations are comparable uh and
um as for uh
distinguishing between uh different
copper forms uh i believe we
haven't done that uh however elena
probably knows more about this yeah
yeah yeah so yes sir actually she's here
so she can add if she wants
um if i'll miss something so yes this is
very good excellent point to harness
indeed
in order to be able to compare you
really have what we do we actually put
our sample side by side
so what do we see here it was done it
was scanned at once
so it is comparable that the difficulty
that we are having although in this case
it's nearly old enough or nothing right
compare if you look at the double mutant
versus
each of the mutants one of the issues
that we were considering before is the
thickness of the sample right because if
the sample if the plant tissue is
thinner because of it's just smaller
it's just because of copper deficiencies
etc
then you will be assuming that it's less
copper but
you know so that's a difficulty so he
overcame this difficulty with
you know like an excellent tool that has
been developed here a chess it's called
it called confocal
uh synchronous ray fluorescent
microscopy so basically what
what this tool allows you is to take
optical section
and actually uh measure intensities
uh in in in a defined
thickness so this is not what it is
currently but we've done it and we know
that we can do it
and we've done it and we compress so
basically results are reproducible and
we can do it like an
and well at five microns
i mean they can go lower but five micron
this is a reasonable resolution
with copper speciation is also very i
mean
it's it's something that we would be
interested in right
uh copper as you know uh and probably
many of you appreciate is
you know it can be toxic actually copper
is considered to be more toxic than iron
in a cell and copper doesn't hang
by itself like you won't if if it's free
in a free ionic state then it's toxic
and so even movement of copper in the
cell
you know it has to be controlled and
there are chaperones that move copper to
enzymes etc and there are a whole bunch
of ligands that
help to move copper and so of course to
know how copper
in which form in which state is it
cooper one of operator two
is it with s's is it with negotiating
we want to know and we can also do it
well we can do it at chess
once it's yeah you can do zayn's
exhausts etc so there are there are
opportunities there yeah
um rich dan do you do you want to add i
know that russian is somewhere around
but i don't know
uh no i think that you already answered
the question
very well so yeah so richard is our
so we you know like she started this
work at chess and now
we are moving to brookhaven so kind of
right i kind of yeah
that's her baby
other questions all right
so i think we are just on time um
it's 1 31 so let's thank for a nice
presentation and good luck with
phd degree and other
studies thank you i applaud i know yeah
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu